Thank you to squarespace for sponsoring
this video
for as long as we know the existence of
border walls and boundaries have gone
hand in hand with the development of
civilization and the human experience as
a whole and the evilness 2015 film
sicario disorder manifests itself in the
physical fence,
separating cartel infested Mexico from
the United States.
However,
the violence and chaos of the
neighboring country is slowly but surely
creeping its way into the backyard of
the American society,
unseen by most yet visible and ever
grown to dos who know where to look.
Kate Macer as part of an FBI getting
that response unit that's been engaged
in cleaning up the mess of this ever
expanding problem in a lot of ways.
Her story is similar to that of Keller
Dover from Vilnius,
prisoners,
kate or Macer to her colleagues is again
a character with a strong moral compass
and a principle belief system as a
strict agent of order and the law she
believes in speaking the truth without
question the statement,
what do you want me to stay to work the
truth with our last name?
Appropriately reflecting her disposition
as a strong representative of justice
and the law and liked the inciting
incident of the illness,
kidnapping mystery.
It is a southern and unexpectedly
malevolent event that kickstarts the
protagonist journey into a confusing,
morally chaotic world where her belief
system will be tested and blur to its
core.
Just traumatic event push escapes.
You volunteer for a task force led by
the ambiguous and unconventional Matt
Graves with a mission devil take her to
the border of a country as well as the
boundary of her own lawful world.
According to Jonathan,
the archetype of the board are commonly
symbolizes the world at the limit,
a place at the bottom,
and at the margin.
It's a symbol of a place in the
periphery that protects the order of the
center from the chaos of the unknown,
but it's often also a realm Verdi's.
Two categories meet and become
interlinked and where it a difference
between the two isn't always obvious and
thus it's a place where to garden.
Heroes tend to be shown as hybrid beings
of sorts.
Possessing elements from both sides of
the border
for Matt and his team working in between
the lines of the law is the only way to
effectively protect the center.
Matt is shown to be both a
representative of order
as well as an agent of chaos.
Doing here is you're giving us the
opportunity to shake the tree,
create chaos.
That's what it is.
There's moral hybridity is further
depicted through aerial shots of the
boarder landscape with it's beige colors
and rugged terrain,
promoting descents of moral ambiguity.
Kate being an emissary of law and order
with the illuminating light of moral
truth shining onto her,
goes into the unknown.
Unprepared and ill equipped attempting
to stay within the confines of the law,
but ultimately being unable to keep the
chaos from invading her world.
Symbolical level of Kate's initial
vision of our journey starts off fairly
archetypical.
The cartels did devils that threatened
to order and harmony of the center or
seem to be infiltrating ever deeper into
the country.
To restore this order and bring those
responsible to justice,
she has to descend into chaos,
into the layer of the snake or the Cave
of the beast.
This beast initially become strongly
identified with the violence of the
cartels in general,
and the city of chorus in particular
is obese.
However,
her fellow task force members seemed to
be participating and even reveling in
the lawlessness of the city.
Brilliant what they do when they
mutilated body like that.
As a representative of the law.
Kate's presence then begins to put an
increasing amount of physical and mental
pressure on her conscience as she
quickly picks up smoking to cope with
this new reality.
This evolution is mirrored by the
character of Sylvio,
serving as a cautionary tale for Kate
Sylvio is her Mexican counterpart in law
enforcement,
a godly man,
and a father of a son who is desperately
trying to keep away from the chaos of
the outside world as much as possible.
No.
However,
it's revealed that Sylvia has been
corrupted by the cartel and is quite
obviously struggling with this reality
as he's often framed in a shadow smoking
cigarettes by the dozens and using
alcohol to set up a barrier for his own
conscience,
but whereas Sylvia's principals have
already been sacrificed,
skate is showing you still be fighting
for hers.
Yeah,
that was fucking illegal.
You want to start a war,
but it's not long thereafter that she to
realize is that the order she represents
has been turning a blind eye to the
activities of maths,
hybrid heroes.
So if your fear is operating out of
bounds,
I am telling you you are not.
Boundaries been moved.
This granting or permission by Kate
Superior symbolizes the archetype of the
wise skiing or fodder culture,
turning a blind eye or being naive or
oblivious due to dealing with chaotic,
tyrannical,
broader or advisor,
and it's this looking away that allows
for the boundary of operational
procedures to be shifted across the
border and it has a helping hand and
blurring the boundaries of order and
chaos and that represents gates own or
change in her world view.
Pivotal in this individual shift of
boundaries are to characters of Reggie
and Alejandro.
Reggie is shown to be kate's most
trusted friend into force and symbolizes
every aspect of kate that aligns with
truth,
law and order,
and it's precisely because of this that
Matt does not want him on his team.
Reggie functions as irrational moral
guide of order for Kate always seeing
dressed in blue and guiding k to seek
the truth and state in line with the
code of law
cake,
but
you don't have to do this.
Alejandro on the other hand is somewhat
of the polar opposite of Reggie being
driven by strong emotional feelings of
hatred.
The former prosecutor turned lawless,
hitman works for anyone who will set him
loose on the people who killed his wife
and daughter.
Alejandro is an agent of chaos,
a mysterious man.
A few words often seen shrouded by
darkness,
but ever present in the background.
He is a man who seems to have lost most
of his humanity along the way,
either being referred to bias John Wick
like nickname or as an animal or
fencing,
and even a Frankenstein monster or
emissary of the devil as he sets his
sights on Fausto,
all our con,
the man responsible for the destruction
of his family appropriately named effort
go to faust,
a man who has sold his soul to the devil
and who ultimately has to face the
consequences.
Both these two characters influenced
gate and seem to function as agents of
order and chaos respectively,
both from the real world as well as
symbolically indicates own internal
world.
We can see how Reggie's influence over
gate starts to dwindle as he unknowingly
sets her up with her would be hitman
with our orderly site,
blinded.
It's only fitting then at.
Alondra appears over her like a shadow
just at the right time.
After this moment,
it is Alejandro who moves into the
foreground and takes on a role as her
guardian.
This unconscious shift into chaos can
also be seen in Kate's increasing lack
of personal hygiene,
and it's a shift that comes to a climax
in the mace,
like layer of the beast,
both Reggie and all 100 venture into
different paths and although Reggie
orders k to stay behind him,
she chooses to follow 100 instead and
it's here at the center of the maze that
she discovers that her supposed to
protect her and her and Zack agonist are
one and the same and ironically it's in
her personal mission to tame chaos back
into order that she herself is the one
who was brought to her knees in the end
to perceive archetypal narrative of the
hero slaying the beast who terrorizes
the land is then suddenly subverted by a
story more akin to that of the garden of
Eden cade wanting to deal with the
increasing infestation of chaos as a
representative of order was unknowingly
lured into tigray world of the
periphery.
Tempted by the potential outcome of
finally dealing with the layer of the
snake to goodbye from the apple.
Only to realize that dealing with one
snake would only allow for another to
rise to power.
In the end,
she's left shrouded from the light that
had one shine onto her having been made
conscious overall mortality and
fragility as well as that of the order
she serves.
Alejandro forces her to finally sign
away her principles,
the last holdout for the boundary that
is now collapsing all around her and
escaped his left,
broken and alone.
A new force moves into the foreground
emerging as a representative of chaos.
Alejandro replaces the core stuff.
The father who's death has just been
signed and echoes in a new era in which
the boundaries of the order of law have
no place.
Alright guys,
thank you all so much for watching and
thank you to squarespace for sponsoring
this video.
As far as easy and convenient website
bill and goes,
squarespace is a godsend.
People have been asking me whether
storytellers has its own website.
As you know,
it's pretty much a necessity in today's
world,
but since I don't know a single thing
about coding and I don't feel
comfortable spending money on something,
I might not be satisfied with the end
we've gotten,
have been holding off on building one
until now,
uh,
with squarespace or wherever.
You get a free trial so you can build
your website before you even have to pay
for a single thing and you know,
you can always change your mind if
you're not satisfied with the result.
Besides that,
you'll get access to countless award
winning templates,
making building a great looking website
easy.
Even for people like myself,
our website isn't quite done yet,
but you can already click on the link in
the description and sign up for your own
free trial.
After that,
you can use our special promo code
storytellers with which you'll get 10
percent off your first purchase.
If you decide to use squarespace and
wants to support us,
make sure you use that code.
Storytellers,
it helps us both out.
Of course,
if you wish to support us in any other
way,
you can also check out our patron page
for storage at our stickers,
or you can leave a tip on paypal.
Thanks for watching guys.
See you in the next one.